there's uh this continued rift that is
taking place
within right wing media at this point in
time one element of this is that once
again
supposedly fox news is refusing to air
my pillow ads for mike lindell's company
my pillow we've talked about some
aspects of this before
my pillow is a company
owned by the right winger mike lindell
who's been a guest on this program that
sells pillows and other elements of
sleeping
and they
used to advertise all the time on fox
news
would spend a ton of money advertising
on fox news and presumably get a pretty
good return for it that's why he kept
doing it and fox news has now on
multiple occasions supposedly refused to
air his ads in part it is believed to be
because of the connection between mike
lindell and false claims about the 2020
election uh there's a new article in
salon which says mike lindell is begging
fox news to start airing his ads again
but the network refuses lindell wants
his ads back on fox but it appears the
cable behemoth isn't ready to take him
back quite yet
the mypillow ceo angrily pulled his
company's advertisements from fox in
july after it ignored the lead-up to a
south dakota cyber symposium and
declined to run an ad for the gathering
but after nearly two months away
the betting magnate appears to finally
be ready to make up with the
conservative network lindell laid out
the situation says he's been trying to
increase
uh to air increasingly watered down
versions of his ads
but that fox news uh doesn't like it
let's go to an interview with mike
lindell this guy really seems off his
rocker but if it is indeed true that fox
is refusing to air them it could signal
an interesting sort of a line in the
sand even for fox news as far as ads go
let's listen
because i don't know what swim is going
to write he's you know he's so far left
you can't even see him and it's so far
left he takes a corner and uh he'll even
tell you that but he's very i like him
though because he's very you know he'll
read back to me at least what my quotes
were so here's the facts um
i you know everybody before the cyber
symposium i put out an ad on fox
telling people about frank speech.com
and the cyber symposium i put that out
to every station in the country fox news
was the only one that denied that ad
that includes your cnns msnbc's abc
cbs's remember i advertise everywhere
with my pillow and this was an ad that
was accepted for frank directing people
to the cyber support to watch the cyber
symposium you guys are following this
right that's all it was so when fox
can't when fox would not allow that what
did not want to be part of this cancer
culture with and had it with them shame
on fox so i cancelled all my pillow ads
right now that's interesting that a
private company saying we don't want
your business
is cancel culture as far as mike pillow
is concerned
then we put an ad up two weeks later
everybody
and after the cyber symposium and that
one said hey just go to frank's speech
and you can see great great shows uh and
you can see the if you missed the cyber
symposium well that's not truth in
advertising there are not great shows on
frank's speech that would be a lie
fox was the only one in the country that
denied that in
then this week
early last week i put another ad i said
nothing about the cyber symposium i said
go to frankspeach.com
you can see great shows we showed some
of the shows your diamond and silks all
the shows diamond and silk are now on
frank's speech can you imagine what is
happening to this country
and you can get great products from my
pillow and my store
we did that and by the way do you guys
hear what sound like whippets happening
in the background fox said
that they didn't like the content of the
ad they didn't like us to say
uh oh no the first two ads they said was
about symposium they didn't like the
content of the ads that's why they
wouldn't take them because it said
symposium right
then this third ad fox said they didn't
like the content over at frank's speech
there's either a woodpecker or someone's
huffing whippets peach brandon they
didn't like their show they don't wait
what fox doesn't like my show
i guess not and know but that's no no
you know it gets worse everybody so they
said remember they said one they didn't
like the content of the ad two they
didn't like the content yet three
they didn't like the content
of the
platform the website frank speech the
stuff that was on printspeech.com all
right what a victim huh guys there's
it's just horrible what's going on with
mike pillow um what's interesting about
this the noise in the background is
interesting i will admit but it's it's
very interesting
that there is now this entire wing of
the right the diamond and silk mike
pillow
etc newsmax oan wing
it's too radical for fox news like at
the end of the day fox's right wing
but fox wants to make money they want to
be in rather than out and you even now
have people who watch newsmax saying fox
has become left wing the mike pillow
types the january 6 types and others and
newsmax is now running an ad i'll play
it on a live stream i don't think i'll
talk about it on the podcast but i'll
play it on an upcoming live stream
there's newsmax now has an ad
where in the ad it's audio of trump
saying
fox is uh so so but newsmax is doing
really well at this point in time so a
very strange rift happening within
right-wing media but even fox news
saying some of this stuff is even too
crazy for us
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video